hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to should
wrestle they're starring movies this is
the question has plagued mankind for
centuries on the one hand it seems ideal
I mean they're already sort of acting
aren't they I mean the wrestlers they
know how to play to the crowd they know
how to make everything look the mattock
is practically in the blood on the other
hand suburban command
this is a movie starring the whole star
as an intergalactic freedom fighter
trying to hide out in middle-class
suburbia what's that that's even too
crappy to be a TGIF sitcom Wow let's
take a look and see why this sci-fi flop
is just as bad as itself first of all
tell me this opening rings anything else
rip all this is a ripoff this is a
ripoff are you kidding
it turns out the sinister bald guy in
cher is planning to conquer every
intergalactic brouhaha and his kidnap
the president of he won't be around for
long so who cares bill I try to live a
life Ramsey you're insane
no no not that Ramsey this guy Oh Cole
gameplays the superhero Chef Ramsay
don't kid no not Chef Ramsay chef no not
that Chef as a cheapy why does he have
that name I don't know maybe he was born
from a celebrity or something so what's
down the set that even Spaceballs would
be embarrassed to have as he beats up
some canned guys oh man our girly
haircuts won't save us this time going
up
going down going up going down sorry
that's all I know how to say
why do all the henchmen in this world
look like his fans are Tonya Harding
he's mine it's been nice knowing you
chef though the others goody-goody
I'm sorry what he uses an envelope to
cut off a man's hand how does that work
so I guess because his hand is cut off
he's supposed to turn into some sort of
vomit monster for some reason by now
so long mr. president to look with that
whole muster killing you thing I'm just
gonna designate the ship and run away
like a coward
all right the president is dead go
Ramsey stabilize with me yeah what do
you think the odds are they will run
into Darth Vader after getting blown up
from the Death Star watch it dick cheese
excellent work Ramsey the shiet system
can now live without threat of
annihilation by general suitor millions
are in your debt all except for that one
tiny detail what was it again ah yes you
to the president you friggin idiot great
so what's next world leader assembly I
hope I actually would be evil general
after the way I things are pretty quiet
you gotta have something on your books
may be a terrorist extermination no
galactic narc duty uh ah okay how about
a big bug hunt with creatures that bleed
acid no now stop referencing sci-fi
films without better than this one so he
accidentally damages his ship which
means he has to lay low on a planet
until it recharges how long you might
ask recharge no higher than 0.01%
it'll take me six weeks to recharge what
am I gonna do for six weeks maybe some
acting lessons would be a good idea so
is the credits roll or greeted to a nice
suburban wrap get ready to potty that's
what I'm saying
get up get your body swim what dollar
bottles a thousand they wanna beat them
yeah that's good but it's not I'm gonna
jump funky lyrics so we go to our other
star them will be Christopher Lloyd
playing an architect named Charlie you
dad gonna grab tell your mom I'll be
right in
I'm working on my flux capacitor
yourself
he's married to a decomposing codfish I
mean Shelley Duvall and she tries to
give him advice about asking for a raise
you've got that race uh honey costume
designer on the Gaian wouldn't like that
so after the rat song stops barking
Charlie finally gets up the nerve to ask
for a raise
I'm trying to say I know what you're
trying to say come on Charlie Charlie
Charlie look at me be with me now come
on now come on boy this is sexual
harassment and I don't have to take it
so he doesn't get the raise but he does
get a comedy boy Ramsay lands and tries
to find a place to stay while his ship
recharges Moochie judging by those
incredible directions that sign just
gave me my guess is the apartment is
somewhere the Harwich we then cut to a
scene where charlie is hag racing with
some old geezers the finds II just can't
run the yellow light
down
that's not funny but don't worry it's a
running joke
so they'll repeated several times until
you have no choice but to find it funny
but who am I to argue with running jokes
big lapel gear moment elephant chuck
norris so he returns home where his wife
thinks that he asked for his raise so
she wants to congratulate it by all god
no no no no no no no no no I was showing
a ball please I just thought you sounded
so sad on the phone yeah it looks like a
mix between sharing incredible mr.
Winton thanks anyway no no spanking no
lingerie as far as I'm concerned this is
a sexless marriage I know they had two
kids but that's what orphanages are for
thank God somebody rings the doorbell
and interrupts our I don't want to know
what much I'm here to rent the apartment
so Lindsey comes into the picture and
tries his best to fit in I can't believe
you rented out to that guy's enormous
and he's probably dangerous all worst
jokes all my floor but Charlie sneaks a
peek at Randy settling in because he
simply doesn't trust him or at least I
hope that's why he sneaking a peek at
him Oh God he's so much more attractive
than my wife he finds one of his ray
guns and accidentally transit I which
allows interstellar bad guys to track
him down commander we've got a traceable
power sources
can you pinpoint it I'm working on it
now sir let me just finish playing my
game of pac-man fest
so wily tracking down our hero continues
to encounter some misunderstandings
about suburban life
Wow
it's Marsha Marsha a TV show this is all
happens that today is about screaming
for health you know to get out all those
internal pensions before it becomes
mental stress yes and that's week is
running down the middle of the street
shouting rape to ease the tension he
also tried skateboarding with Charlie
Sun but that seems to backfire as well
monka Stan longer naps dawn what a week
meanwhile then running Joe returns to
set up a most likely disappointing
payoff
what is it with them anyway did it
yellow light eat his dog or something
what kind of world is this so the
neighbors car is very rudely blocking
Charlie's driveway which results in
Ramsey moving it out of the way
hey golly laughs that was fun
you got any idea what we're gonna do to
you we find one anybody scratch on him
let me guess you're gonna pound my face
break every bone in my body then you're
gonna drag me across the gravel road and
feed my remains to a warthog is that
about right cuz that would really turn
me on what are you nuts it's the
nineties we're gonna see now it's also
funny then we'll be clearly to have been
about these guys you'll be hearing from
our attorney Oh he also saves the life
of Charlie's son because apparently he
came here an incredibly fast moving
vehicle with the music blasting as loud
as a cat
Oh Smosh so he flips the car over and
throws the guys out of the vehicle so
what does he get for injuring others and
destroying someone else's property okay
yep this is for you an appreciation of
everything you've done for
thank you for senselessly beating people
and scaring the shit out of the
neighborhood but Charlie still doesn't
trust Ramsey so he follows him around
some more it's no use I can hear your
sneaking music so I guess he just goes
out the middle of the night looking for
crimes to fight God doesn't this guy
ever sleep
ma'am if you'll excuse me I have to use
your face and watchful feel really
because it looks like afterburner you
know that game about Jets and not space
aliens afterburner give it up give it up
give it up dragos give it up
goddamn that's a burner it's a game made
in 1987 by the sega corporations have to
run after her ha ha ha
you just saved the galaxy
you must play this game a lot game what
game so Charlie finds Ramsey's robotic
suit and rather than quenching it he
simply decides to put it on and fight
crime himself yes this is back in the
day when all dead men wanted to do was
just pull it when the mouse repeatedly
its gizmo duck by the way what is that
thing for does every super suit just
come with an automatic crotch water
doesn't have to be that way so what
ranting checks a scanner to see if
there's any black people in this movie
he comes across an unfortunate discovery
bounty hunters we don't need that scum
he thinks Charlie is to blame so he goes
to his work to see him and where's
Charlie Wilcox in a meeting can't be
disturbed leave a message or take a seat
I said take a seat and if you dare do
the joke I know you're thinking of oh
you are scum where's my you gentle riser
did you follow me to my ship yes you
fool with my stuff ah where's my auntie
Jenna horizon
so Hulk Hogan and Christopher boy get in
a car and no that's not the beginning of
a bad joke to hunt down the weapon
that's leading the tracking signal you
said maybe that they may find their way
here they may not get an exact fix it
could pass us right by if no more flares
are sent up that's why you gotta get
that end
singing back right right you know I
gotta admit you're taking this whole me
being an alien thing pretty well most
people would have questions or something
but you seem pretty cool with it we can
find them with this
it's zeroes in on the guns electronic
signal how much wait a minute that's the
peak 18 meter from ghostbusters
good god Regis raving dead accurate
storage locker so it turns out the
crooks from the other night stole that
weapon they start using it as a freeze
gun no I'm not going there
as they use it to break into banks and
steal money oh boy now we can just pay
women to let us pull their arms Ramsey
gets the gun back but charlie is frozen
in the process on top of that the evil
bounty hunters arrive and start randomly
shooting the law mildly annoying but not
really that's right
so Randy gets Charlie home hopefully not
going through any tunnels as he follows
him out in his shit they're here who's
here a couple of leeches that make their
living off the blood of others I'm gonna
say the producers bounty hunters that
was my next choice so while suiting up
Randy s Charlie for health and defeating
these evildoers it's your fault they're
here my fault yeah
how the hell was I supposed to know that
you were some sort of alien Rambo and
then Charlie says probably one of my
favorite out-of-context lines of all
time
Christ I was frozen today i friggin love
that line
let me hear it again I was frozen today
just out of nowhere the next time you're
in the middle of an argument with
someone just say it just say it out of
nowhere for example you'll be like don't
act like you know what I'm going through
you have no idea what I'm going through
don't act like you're king of the
universe all the time we're very hard to
get where I add hard work you have no
idea what hard work I was
Rosen today
say it at parties family get-togethers
whatever just sit back and enjoy some of
the most awkward expressions you've ever
seen in your entire life
pie was frozen today anyway back to the
story it turns out the only thing to fix
Ramsay shit faster are these crystals
that Charlie's boss happens to have so
they try to sneak in after business
hours to get them but the boss is
entertaining right you make the
alterations I specified oh yes yes yes
I left them down on the car I'll go and
pick him up and bring him to you're off
good splendid one more thing will I be
astonished I think so
I almost kissed you but I wouldn't I was
frozen
today you see I already forget about
what the previous line was it's that
good
so the Bounty Hunter's find him and they
have themselves a somewhat creative but
mostly boring fight scene I have to
admit any action sequence that gets a
toilet on someone's head is at least try
you're a good man Ramsey no wonder you
guys never talked only Hulk Hogan could
wear that trick so of course they defeat
the bounty hunters as Ramsey and Charlie
get ready to watch the ship Charlie do
me a favor go back to my place to make
sure I've got everything I don't want to
risk leaving even one of those traceable
devices behind
we don't need sequels charlie we don't
want anything calling him back okay
Jenny I was frozen today the more shiny
scalp is apparently still alive as he
threatens Charlie and his family if
Francie doesn't turn himself in this is
how you're gonna do me in by boring me
to death with speeches Oh unfortunately
for you you're going to die much more
painfully could I end besides my words
any more but the family escapes as
Charlie rushes in and tries to stop the
evil villain was transformed into a lady
when did he turn into the Emperor from
the Black Lagoon
I love cheering on my stupid things it
allows my enemies plenty of time for
them to destroy it
oh yeah pretty much like that
so Ramsey and Charlie make it out alive
as Ramsey plans to lead earth once and
for all but not before tying up some
loose ends wait what did he learn
skateboarding from the surf ninja kid
remember bend your knees you you so you
kids on his ship says goodbye takes off
from a skyscraper yeah because nobody
will notice a spaceship leaving in broad
daylight on top of a skyscraper but wait
a minute what about that running yellow
light joke
really you're gonna end on that just
shooting the light we wait it through
two unfunny scenes they had to close
down this whole friggin highway of
delaying traffic for god knows how long
just for that something is down today
wrong movie
so that's suburban commando and well
certainly not a good movie I will give
it credit and he's got a chuckle out of
me here and there which is more than I
can say for some other films but for the
most part is just stupid the only
contribution to cinema it's ever made is
I was frozen today
I'm serious just try it out see what
happens I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
and it was afterburner shut up